skyscraper is directed by the man behind
dodgeball if you can dodge a wrench you
can dodge a ball and Central
Intelligence which also started the rock
like this film which is about a father
who goes to extreme lengths to get his
family to safety when they are trapped
in a burning building this building just
so happens to be the tallest ever
constructed he's a security consultant
that was hired to make sure it was safe
for the public but a scheme arises with
some evil people that set the building
on fire and now they're trapped inside
and he has to try to figure out how to
rescue them when the trailer for this
film debuted a lot of people compared it
to the action classic die hard so many
people in fact that the marketing team
decided to embrace it creating a mock-up
poster in the original fashion of die
hard as well as the towering inferno and
so you can go to this film and say well
you know they're embracing it because
they released those posters and we're
supposed to accept the fact that this
film is a gigantic derivative copycat of
other films that are far better and just
turned our brains off right well I
couldn't I found this film terrible I
really did there is barely an original
idea in this entire picture this might
sound like an exaggerated statement but
I assure you it isn't almost every
single action scene in the film felt
lifted from something else that did it
better there's a shot that is straight
out of Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol
and two entire sequences that feel just
like that film so much so that when I
saw with my buddy John he leaned over
during the shot and was like Mission
Impossible Ghost Protocol and I leaned
over and I was like yeah I haven't read
any reviews yet but I can only assume
based off of those mock-up posters that
the studio felt they had to release to
sort of calm the storm that was this
movie I can only assume people are also
making these comparisons and so I'm
you've probably heard this before but
this film really does feel like it's a
completely unoriginal mess as usual The
Rock is probably the most entertaining
aspect of this film but he has
definitely been better before this is
not one of his better films or one of
his better performances although he
isn't bad in the movie I've just seen
him with more charisma his character is
just father who wants his family back I
don't understand why a star of his
number one of if not the highest-paid
actor in Hollywood right now would take
a role that's so simple and watered-down
in fact that's kind of what he's been
doing lately he's been making a lot of
pg-13 films that people forget almost
instantly is anyone talking about
rampage anymore that came out this year
and I fear this film will have a similar
fate because there are 10 movies that
are similar and all of them are better
this is a 125 million dollar action film
and I don't understand why that kind of
money has been thrown to a script that
is so blatantly derivative of other
material alright but for argument's sake
let's just throw away the originality
argument and focus on the film without
comparing it to other films even when
you do that the film has a very
artificial movie studio green-screen
glossy Sheen to it all it just doesn't
feel real
I barely bought into a single thing that
happened the action felt so censored
bloodless the violence felt very weak it
didn't really feel like anything was
happening the best part of the film was
the opening scene which is very sad and
very tragic but a lot of it has to do
with the fact that I hadn't seen the
rest of the movie yet and so I was sort
of invested still but that ended very
quickly as far as the villains go I mean
there's so many and they they're
ever-shifting it's like one person will
be bad then it'll be okay and then maybe
the other guy is not so great and you're
not entirely sure what's going on and
twists and turns are fine and all but
when your film doesn't really have a
presence that's to be feared
and I suppose the main villain of the
movie is just like the lead mercenary
and and he's just evil honestly this is
the epitome of Hollywood watered-down
forgettable action again I didn't buy a
single moment of the film I thought it
was extremely fake looking and there's a
billion other movies just like this one
that are insanely better in every way
I'm gonna give skyscraper a d-plus but I
do want to say a big thank you to Dollar
Shave Club they've been doing a
sponsorship on my channel you can check
out the link in the description below to
learn more about their $5 daily
essentials starter kit please do that
it's a fantastic deal thank you very
much Dollar Shave Club let's just say
you had to take this plot this was the
story the script could not be changed
this was the movie that was
to be made he had the budget you had the
approval you could make this movie at
least 10 times better by just making it
rated R I don't understand why these
movies have to be so like kid-friendly
and like approved for the masses it's
there's no there's no depths you know it
didn't feel like there was any grit to
it it could have been so much better
with just that one simple choice maybe
they wouldn't have got as big of a
budget but perhaps that could have been
better because so many of the action
sequences didn't look real because they
were relying on so much green screen
technology that it just I didn't really
buy into it
this movie was disappointing it could
have been a lot better and and even as
like a turn your brain off action movie
I couldn't really get into it either
because it just reminded me of a billion
other things Wow I had a lot more to say
about skyscraper than I expected
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]